today's big event in Washington DC was a
rally sponsored by the Tea Party
Patriots against the Iran nuclear deal
the event drew several hundred people
who showed equal amounts of contempt for
the Islamic Republic of Iran President
Barack Obama and the congressional
leadership of the Republican Party there
doesn't seem to be a clear libertarian
position on the Iran deal some think
it's a good start on opening a ran up to
moderating Western influence while
others think it doesn't do enough to
keep the mullahs nuclear ambitions at
bay reason TV caught up with Glenn back
of the blaze radio host and vessel or
Mark Levin and former congresswoman
Michele Bachmann all of whom were act on
establishment Republicans as much or
more as they did on Harry Reid Barack
Obama and Islamic clerics and we managed
also to find out what Donald Trump the
big draw today's event
thinks about libertarians a lot of good
things I don't want to talk to you now
but a lot of good things a lot of good
points you want to name one of them
fellas be careful reason yes what can
you what did we say about reason I don't
always agree but I love it anybody who's
kicking ass and challenging the
establishment I like what is your
message here today my message here today
is we should not be giving the Islamic
Nazis nukes and we certainly should be
giving them 150 billion dollars to play
with what what's a better outcome then
is it no deal or a better deal better
outcome is for the Republicans in the
Senate to finally treat this as a treaty
that's what the Constitution says it's
2/3 of the Senators present doesn't
matter and they keep getting these
Democrats to announce and then vote it
down but they won't do it
what is is this more a failure of the
Republican Party or a kind of a problem
of Obama oh I'm seeing less and less
difference between the Republican
leadership and the Democrat leadership
can you tell me any difference between
Harry Reid run in the Senate Mitch
McConnell
in the Senate and under Speaker Boehner
Obama's gotten every damn thing that
he's wanted so I think conservatives and
libertarians who do identify as
Republicans we're drawing a line we've
had enough Reagan said in 77 it's time
for a new Republican Party it's time for
a new Republican Party
do you see the Iran deal more as a
failure of Republic of the Republican
Party or a Barack Obama's administration
of all of them of all of them and
including the American people I mean
we're so blind now that we can't see
good and evil side by side we can't say
that state forget about spiritual stuff
that state produces healthy people and
life that state produces death and we're
choosing death which one is which and
that Israel and Iran so what what is
your preferred outcome if this deal is
no good what's the deal that you're
looking for or is there a deal that's
possible I'm so far beyond deals I don't
have any idea what people in Washington
or people around the world are even
gonna do I just want to be known as
standing for life and not standing for
people who say hey by the way I'm gonna
vaporize you when they what when we were
in this negotiation
rou-ha-nee actually said it's easy to
say death to America it's time we put
our words into action do so is this
about Israel or is it about America it's
about life it's about anybody who's
standing for life so what do you do to
contain Iran what do you do to liberate
its people short of war well I hope that
I think war is absolutely insane I don't
think that there is a way I mean we have
so botched this from the beginning we're
on this endless roller coaster of war
now the worst thing we can do is war but
one thing we can't do is give them a
hundred and fifty billion dollars what
what are we doing do you think if we
engage the Iranian people through
commerce and trade that that would that
would overturn the Islamic Republic the
best thing we could have done is when
the Reformers stood up in the streets to
hear their voices we heard the voices
when they were the Muslim Brotherhood in
Egypt we
Nord the voices of people in Iran the
best thing we can do is encourage the
good people in Iran we're not doing that
we're we are on all of the wrong sides
well we were busy invading Iraq at the
time right back in the early 2000s no
that happened under the Obama
administration yes we were still in Iraq
and we were still doing that but there
was no excuse for not standing that you
know I think we've all learned maybe you
haven't cuz you were clear from the
get-go but many of us look at what
happened in Iraq and now go WOW crap
we were really foolish for doing this we
were fooled we you want to do something
for September 11th we should have gone
in got the bad guys and get the hell out
of there that shouldn't have we're still
there what are we doing so the worst
thing we can do is promise more war and
flex our muscle it's insane what what
kind of deal do we need with a rally
well the deal is Iran has no nuclear
program they completely dismantle their
nuclear program they shouldn't be
allowed to have anything and the good
news is we could take that out today we
have them we have the military ability
to destroy their milk their nuclear
hardware today we're not talking about
bot dropping bombs on shopping centers
and killing innocent kids we're talking
about taking out the means of
destruction you're in favor of bombing
Iran today because they're in they
haven't followed the rules favor of
ending Iran's nuclear program what
unfortunately what President Obama wants
to do is enrich Iran to the point where
they're going to be a trillion dollar
terror state within ten years
today the ayatollah tweeted that israel
won't exist within 25 years if iran has
an immediate access to 150 billion
dollars they will build their nuclear
program they will arm their terrorist
proxies and they will fulfill their
mission which is the annihilation of the
Jews
so what is wrong with the Republican
Party that they're not following what
you want it's inexplicable it isn't what
I want it's what federal law says
because the corker bills States
unequivocally if the president doesn't
give Congress the full Iran agreement to
read
then the sanctions stand that's it our
sanctions good but I mean don't they
hurt poor people the most and have they
really destabilized their Iranian regime
not at all what we saw is that sanctions
actually were extremely effective but
sanctions won't end the nuclear program
the only thing that we in history that
has ended nuclear problems programs has
been that literal physical taking out of
those programs through bombings